SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN OUR JULY. ACTIONS
BACKER BOARD BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG
HUESO HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT
SHOW A VOTE PAN PORTANTINO. RAW
RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS
REQUIREMENTS. WHAT ARE MEMBERS
AND GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RIGHTS
WOULD BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR WIENER AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR STERN. STERLING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR PRESIDENT OUR
COLLEAGUES. FIVE TODAY IN HONOR
OF INTERNATIONAL HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. WE PRAY THIS
PRAYER- A DOG A RABBI DAVID
KATZ. ON THIS MOST SOLEMN
OCCASIONS. WE OPEN OUR HEARTS
OUR MINDS AND SOULS TO YOU-
HOLDING ONE. AS WE REMEMBER THE
SIX MILLION. ELEVEN MILLION. THE
INDIFFERENCE AND THE EVIL. AS WE
HONOR THE HEROES. AND MARTYRS OF
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS. WE ASK
YOU TO SUIT OUR SOULS. TO
AMPLIFY OUR MEMORIES TO
STRENGTHEN OUR RESOLVE. AND TO
HEAR OUR PRAYERS. WE ASK FOR
YOUR PRESENCE IN OUR MIDST FOR
HEALING. LIGHT AND LOVE TO
SOUVENIRS ARE PAYING. AS WE
COMMEMORATE THE HORRORS THAT
WERE COMMITTED. NOT LONG AGO.
PLEASE AVOID ONE THE JOHN. WITH
OUR SOUL. WE ASK THAT YOU US FOR
REMEMBER THE STORIES WE HEAR. AS
TELLS OF THE ATROCITIES ARE
SHARED. AS WE RAN COUNTER THE
UNTHINKABLE WE AFTER THESE
MEMORIES BE STRENGTHENED. AND
NEVER FADED AND THE HOPE OF
THOSE WHO REMEMBER THE MISTAKES
OF THE PAST WILL NOT REPEAT
THEM. PLEASE A HOLY ONE
AMPLIFIED- ABILITY TO REMEMBER.
ABOVE ALL WE PRAY FOR SOMEONE.
FOR HOMELESS MPS TO BE
INTERMIXED NOW AND FOREVER AMEN. WELL A PLEASE JOIN WITH ME.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS
BATES AND DOLLY PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING SENATORS
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR US.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
. REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. REMEMBER MOTIONS
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
ADOPTION OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
FOR BUDGET BILLS THAT ARE ACROSS
THE DESK ON FRIDAYS THIRTY AND
SUNDAY JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
TWENTY NINE AND THIRTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED IN THE
MEASURES WILL BE RETURNED TO
COMMITTEE. WE'RE STRUCK FROM THE
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING FILE ITEMS WILL BE
STRICKEN FROM THE FILE ITEMS
THREE THROUGH TWENTY THREE. IN
ADOPTION OF FIRST READING THE
BILL'S SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK AND GENERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FILE
ITEMS. ONE TWO TWO. SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY TWO AND SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY. YOUR BILL MEMBERS
REMOVING THE SENATE THIRD
READING WE HAVE FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE SENATOR CABALLERO ARE YOU
PREPARED SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RING. SENATE BILL THREE
BY SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO EDUCATION FINANCE
CENTER CAREER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE WHICH
WILL PROVIDE THE STATE WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS AND
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF FUNDS
DEDICATED TO CLOSING THE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AMONG OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. FOSTER
STUDENTS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
SB THREE REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP A LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN PORTAL TO
SERVE AS A TRACKING MECHANISMS
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT. ATTORNEY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO REPORT THE SERVICES
THEY PROVIDE TO THE STUDENTS
FUNDED BY SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT
RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS. TO REPORT
SERVICES PROVIDED VIA THE LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
PORTAL THAT IS CREATED ON
MEMBERS WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
GRANTS. EXTRA FUNDS FOR THESE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT THE
FUNDS ARE NOT BEING USED. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE STUDENTS
FOR WHICH THEY WERE GRANTED AND
INSTEAD MANY OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE SWEEPING THE MONEY
INTO THEIR GENERAL FUND AND
USING IT FOR GENERAL PURPOSES
BAD WAS NOT WITH THE MONEY
WASN'T INTENDED TO DO. AND WE'VE
TRIED TO PUT- YOU'LL REMEMBER
THAT ARE. THE COLLEAGUE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY NOW SECRETARY OF STATE
WEBER. RAN A SERIES OF BILLS TO
FORCE ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE USE
OF THESE FUNDS WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET THAT KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THIS WILL REQUIRE
THE REPORTING OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THOSE FUNDS SO
THAT WE CAN COMPARE DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT. WHAT THE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED FOR WHETHER WE THINK
THEY'RE BEING SUCCESSFULLY
DEPLOYED AND WHETHER STUDENTS
ARE ACTUALLY. BENEFITING FROM
THE FUNDS THAT WE GRANTED- SB
THREE WILL MODERNIZE REPORTING
AND CREATE A MECHANISM TO TRACK
THE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION.
RELATED SERVICES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH LOW INCOME AN ENGLISH
LEARNER. WHILE THE TWENTY TWENTY
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL INCLUDED
PROVISIONS FOR THE INITIAL
STAGES OF THE L. TAT PORTAL THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF EQUITY
INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION. ASSESS
THE MEASURES FUNDED TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
PUPILS AND SIMPLIFY EL CAP
REPORTING METHODS TO MAKE
VALUABLE INFORMATION EASIER TO
REPORT AND I AND I IN A
DIGESTIBLE MANNER THE PORTAL
WILL SERVE AS AN ONLINE TOOL TO
IMPROVE THE TRANSPARENCY OF
SPENDING DECISIONS. AND ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS TO ADDRESS EDUCATIONAL
DISPARITIES. THIS BILL HAD
UNANIMOUS THIS BILL HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THERE IS
NO CURRENT OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE I ALSO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT IS A PROUD FATHER
TO THIS BILL. AS THE AUTHOR
STATED TIME WITH SUCH LARGE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IT IS REALLY
IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
WITHIN THESE FUNDS AND THAT THE
MONEY GOES DIRECTLY TO THE
STUDENTS THAT IT WAS INTENDED TO
HELP- I WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE STRUGGLING SO THAT
THAT IS AN ISSUE BUT IF THE
FUNDING WAS MEANT TO SUPPORT
THESE VULNERABLE STUDENTS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
WHAT THE FUNDING GOES. AND SO I
ALSO I JUST WANT TO COME AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS SOMETIMES TO
TRACK THIS FUNDING AND SO WITH
THIS BILL AGES WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR NOT ONLY
ADMINISTRATORS TEACHERS AND OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO UNDERSTAND
BUT IT WILL DEFINITELY IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION OF OUR
STUDENTS AND WITH THAT I
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU. ZERO
WE'RE GONNA STICK TO KEEP DECIDE
CHARTED. SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
ALSO ON A RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I THINK THIS KIND OF-
OVER COUNT IN THE AND LETTING
THE PUBLIC AND ALL OF US KNOW
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON IS
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL EVEN IN THESE
VERY KIND OF THE VISIT TIMES
WHERE WE HAVE A WE KNOW THAT A
LOT OF CONFLICT IS HAPPENING AT
OUR LOCAL LEVELS IN OUR SCHOOL
BOARDS AND LYFT. THE SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE ARE JUST A PLACE OF
DEMOCRACY NOW LIKE WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE AND ALLOW DECISIONS
GET MADE ABOUT ABOUT OUR OUR
CHILDREN AND THE AND THEIR
EDUCATION WE CAN HAVE ALL THE
GOOD IDEAS AS WE WANT ABOUT
PUTTING AS MUCH RESOURCES DOWN
TO THE LOCALS AS WE WANT BUT IF
THAT NOT MONEY IS NOT BEING
GOING OUT TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE
STUDENTS LIVES AND EDUCATIONS
THAN THE MORE DOING SOMETHING
WRONG AND WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
IT. SO I WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS AND IS MUCH OF OVER CAT
AND THIS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IS WE CAN BUILD
INTO OUR GOVERNMENT THE MORE WE
CAN AGREE ON ON WHAT IS AND WHAT
ISN'T AND WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
MAKE SURE KIDS GET EVERYTHING
THEY NEED SO THANKING THE
SENATOR FOR THIS AND RISING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY THE
DESCRIPTION. OF A ON THE SIDE
OF. SEEING ALL THE SCRIPTS
INVADERS. SOONER CABALLERO ARE
CLOSE. YES I WHEN I THINK- ON MY
GOOD COLLEAGUES THROUGH. UP IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. A MANAGER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BACKER. AYE FORGES
AYE BRADFORD. I HAVE ITEM HI
CORTESE AYE DODD DURACELL I
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI
PRASADA HI JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA I LIMON I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A CHOI BOGUE
HI PAM FIVE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER HI STERN
AYE NUMBER HI MY COUNTY I WIENER
. I WILL. MS OUR TO CALL THE
ROLL WOMAN TERM. DODD NIELSEN.
WILK. FIVE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS IT
ZERO MEASURE PASSES THAT MEMBERS
WERE WOUNDED RETURNING TO
MOTIONS REAL RESOLUTIONS NOT TO
TIME FOR YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY WE
HAVE SENATOR JOE VOEPEL ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY
. LARGER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
GAVE DELAROSA WHO WAS A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE FROM MENTONE
GAVE WAS AN ENTHUSIASTIC
ADVOCATE AND VOLUNTEER IN HIS AN
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY OF
FEWER THAN TEN THOUSAND
RESIDENTS HE SERVED AS A
PRESIDENT FOR THE MENTAL
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION AND THE
MENTONE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AS
HIS WIFE AND YOU SAID IT WAS
GAVE NATURE TO BE SOCIABLE AND
HELP HIS COMMUNITY IN THE PAST
HE WAS KNOWN AS THE MAYOR OF
CRESTLINE. WILL STILL REMEMBER
HIM IN THE MOUNTAINS. HE
ORGANIZED PARADESHE
ENTERTAINMENT- SENIOR CENTER AND
LOCAL EVENTS AS A SINGER AND HE
RAN MARKET NIGHT EVENTS AND THE
PET STORE. HE HAD A BEAUTIFUL
AND GIVING HEART AND OFTEN
HANDED OUT FOOD BIBLES AND ITEMS
FROM THE STORE TO HOMELESS
RESIDENTS. HIS DEDICATED
SERVICES COMMUNITY IS WHAT
EARNED HIM HIS UNOFFICIAL TITLE
OF MAYOR. AND UNIFIER OF
MENTONE. OUR COMMUNITY WILL MISS
HIM DEARLY. CAN YOU PLEASE BRING
THE NAME PORTER CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TO
HONOR THE LIFE OF. LARRY D.
MOORE THE SECOND FORMER MERCED
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY DEAR
FRIEND TO MANY OF US PUTTING ME
. PASSED AWAY LAST YEAR AT THE
VERY YOUNG AGE SIXTY FOUR LARRY
WAS BORN ON MARCH TWENTIETH
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN TO PARENTS
LARRY MORE SENIOR ATTORNEY WHO
LATER BECAME A JUDGE AND SARON.
A SCHOOL TEACHER. AFTER BEING
RAISED WITH FIVE SIBLINGS IN
LANCASTER CALIFORNIA LARRY
ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARKANSAS AND RECEIVED HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN JOURNALISM
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. FOLLOWING
COLLEGE LATER WENT ON TO WORK AS
A REPORTER FOR THE ARKANSAS
DEMOCRAT RECEIVED ASSIGNMENTS
INTERVIEW SUCH NOTABLES AS THEN.
GOVERNOR BILL CLINTON. WHILE
WORKING IN LITTLE ROCK WHERE HE
MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE CINDY
ROBERSON. WHO AFTER JUST SEVEN
SHORT YARS HE CONVINCED TO
MARRY HIM. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE LARRY BEGAN A LIFELONG
CAREER IN CIVIC AFFAIRS THAT
WOULD TAKE HIM TO WASH DC
EVENTUALLY TO SACRAMENTO TO
ATTEND UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SUES ME UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC
MCGEORGE. SCHOOL LAW. BY
GRADUATION BECAME INVOLVED IN
LOCAL AND NATIONAL GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS WROTE COUNTLESS SPEECHES
AND LATER SERVED AS THE VOICE.
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. TWO
THOUSAND SIX LAYER WAS ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE COUNTY
MERCED WOULD GO ON TO PROSECUTE
NEARLY TWENTY MURDER CASES.
NUMEROUS CONSUMER FRAUD CASES
INITIATED THE COUNTY'S VIOLENCE
INTERRUPTION PREVENTION BURNS
THE RESPONSE TEAM. IN ADDITION
THIS LERI DEVOTED HIS TIME AS A
MEMBER OF THE GREATER MERCED
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE LOS BANOS
SPORTSMAN'S ASSOCIATION. IT WAS
A FOUNDING BOARD MEMBER OF THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF MERCED
COUNTY. LARRY IS PRECEDED IN
DEATH- SADLY BY HIS SON ETHAN
AND HIS PARENTS. HE LEAVES A
GREAT NUMBER OF FRIENDS HERE
BEHIND IN THE CAPITAL- I THINK
WE CAN THOSE OF US WHO DEALT
WITH LARRY CAN STILL HEAR HIS
DEEP RESONANT VOICE AND LAUGH. I
RINGS IN MY MIND OFTEN- I KNOW
WE HAD A SPECIAL LADY AT ALL
SORTS OF FRIENDS INCLUDING CRAIG
WILSON OF SENATOR JONES IS
STAFF- YEARS- SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF THIRTY FIVE YEARS CINDY
WILL REMEMBER DEARLY BY HER HIS
SONS DYLAN AND RYAN. AND IN
PARTICULAR BY HIS GRANDDAUGHTER
AVA WHO WE TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
TIME AND HIS FIVE SIBLINGS
COLLEAGUES I THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME AS WE ADJOURNED IN
THE MEMORY OF LEARN MORSE.
SENATOR JONES. LEARN MORE IN A
KNOWLEDGE M. AND HIS PRESENCE
HERE IN THE CAPITAL I HE HAS
BEEN A GREAT FRIEND OF MY
OFFICE- AND SPENT MY STAFF AND
HAS HELPED US OUT IMMENSELY AND
I AGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT
ABOUT HIS LAUGH AND HIS VOICE-
WAS. VERY- RECOGNIZABLE AND- WE
WILL MISS HIM HE WAS A HARD
WORKER. AND WAS DEDICATED TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
CENTER NUMBER FOR RECOGNIZING IN
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU IT WILL
BE A TREMENDOUS LOSS TO
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
ACTUALLY BRING THE NAME FOR
TRUTH. MISTER MORRIS CAN BE
PROBABLY MORE A LARGE OR WE HAVE
ONE MORE SENATOR COVER YOUR ARMS
ARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I WANTED TO ADD MY
VOICE. TO THIS COURSE I THINK-
IF YOU'D IF HE'S WATCHING DOWN
TODAY HE'S GETTING A BIG. A BIG
KICK OUT OF US HERE AND- ANY HE
HE HAD. A BIG VOICE BUT HE ALSO
HAD A BIG HEART- I KNEW HIM ON A
PERSONAL BASIS- AS THAT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF MERCED COUNTY WHICH
IS PART OF THE DISTRICT THAT I
SERVE AND HE- HE WAS TOTALLY
INVOLVED IN COMMITTEE ACT.
COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES. I'M HE WAS
SMART. BOB HE HAD A SENSE OF
DUTY. AND HE- HE WAS ALWAYS
TRYING TO UPLIFT PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH ALL OF THE
ACTIVITIES. THAT HE WAS INVOLVED
IN PARTICULAR YOUNG PEOPLE. SO I
WANNA JOIN THE CHORUS OF- OF A
SUPPORT FOR THIS RECOGNITION AND
JUST SAY. LARRY MOORE SAID YOU
WILL BE MISSED. THANK YOU
SENATOR GRAHAM. DIGIMARC OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THAT YOU BRING A
NAME FOR ITSELF MISTER MORRIS
CAN BE PROPERLY MORAL OURS.
THANK YOU. NEXUS SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR YOUR JOURNEY
MEMORY. THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS- TODAY I. SADLY
RISE- TO MEMORIALIZE A DELORES
HELEN HECKINGBOTTOM. DORIS WAS A
MEMBER OF THE SENATE AND
LEGISLATIVE FAMILY- YOU WORK FOR
SENATOR POLANCO AND SENATOR JACK
SCOTT WAS A LONG TIME STAFFER.
IN THE DISTRICT IN THE PASADENA
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY- YOU KNOW THE
WORD ICON IS ALWAYS USED AND-
SHE WAS AN ICON- THE WORD
INSPIRATION IS USED AND SHE WAS
INSPIRATIONAL- SHE WAS ALSO A
FRIEND- AND A MENTOR OF MINE- IT
WAS BENEFICIAL AS A YOUNG
POLITICIAN TO. GET TO KNOW
DELORES TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN I
FIRST STARTED TO- MEET PEOPLE
AND PASADENA ALTADENA AND SHE
ALWAYS WAS KIND. AND WARM AND
HELPFUL. TO THE FULL EXTENT
POSSIBLE AND SO I'M SADDENED SO
PLEASE TO- TO TELL YOU ABOUT THE
LARSA. SHE WAS THE SECOND OF
FOUR CHILDREN BORN MARCH TWENTY
SEVENTH NINETEEN THIRTY ONE IN
NEW ORLEANS LOUISIANA TO EDWARD
AND LILLIAN DO PRE. AFTER SHE
GRADUATED FROM EXIBIDA
PREPARATORY HIGH SCHOOL IN NEW
ORLEANS SHE ENLISTED IN THE
WOMEN'S AUXILIARY ARMY CORPS TO
SERVE OUR COUNTRY. DURING THE
WORSE THIS TIME IN THE ARMY SHE
MET HER HUSBAND LIEUTENANT L. B.
HIGGINBOTTOM AND HAD FOUR
CHILDREN AND MARIE LESLIE L. B.
JUNIOR AND JOHN. AFTER
LIEUTENANT HECKINGBOTTOM RETIRED
FROM THE MILITARY HIS HE IN
DELORES SETTLED IN EL TO DENA.
NOW DELORES AND I'LL BE BEGAN
THEIR EFFORTS TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE INTEGRATION OF THE PASADENA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE
THEIR CHILDREN ATTENDED NO SMALL
FEAT. AND A SIGNIFICANT
ACCOMPLISHMENT WITH THE HELP OF
DELORES TIRELESS EFFORTS L. B.
THEN RAN AND WAS ELECTED TO THE
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. BOARD WHERE HE SERVED
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS. SADLY AFTER
FIFTY TWO YEARS OF MARRIAGE
SHALL BE PASSED AWAY IN TWO
STOP THE LAWRENCE FROM SERVING
HER COMMUNITY BECAUSE SHE IN HER
OWN RIGHT. WAS A TIRELESS
FORMIDABLE ADVOCATE. SHE
CONTINUED TO BE CIVICALLY
ENGAGED AND VERY ACTIVE MEMBER
IN THE PASADENA AND ALTADENA
AREA SHE WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE PALESTINIAN EDUCATION
FOUNDATION. THE PASADENA CHAPTER
OF THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
POLITICAL CAUCUS AND WOMEN IN
ACTION SHE WAS PART OF THE
PASADENA AND DOUBLE ACP. DERAIL
DEMOCRATIC CLUB ACT THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY'S OLDEST LIBERAL
ORGANIZATION AND THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS. THAT'S JUST TO
NAME A FEW OF THE ORGANIZATION'S
DELORES WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER ON.
SHE RECEIVED MAY MANY ACCOLADES
HER CAREER FROM THE PASADENA AND
DOUBLE ACP HE WAS THE RUBY
MCKNIGHT WILLIAMS RECIPIENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS HOLDEN
UNSUNG HERO FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
ALTADENA WOMAN OF THE YEAR
CONGRESSWOMAN JUDY CHU'S WOMAN
OF THE YEAR AND THE CITY OF
PASADENA'S ARTHUR NOBLE CIVIC
AWARD. HERE SURVIVED BY HER FOUR
CHILDREN AND MARIE LESLIE L. B.
JUNIOR AND JOHN GRANDCHILDREN'S
JOHN JUNIOR HELENA AND AGNES AND
A HOST. OF FAMILY MEMBERS.
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT SHE
TRULY WAS A SPECIAL ONE OF A
KIND PERSON HE WAS SMALL.
QUIETLY CONFIDENT UNASSUMING BUT
UNABASHEDLY PASSIONATE AND
TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR UMAN RIGHTS FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS. AND SHE TOOK A
KIND MOMENT TO SHARE HER WISDOM
WITH THIS YOUNG POLITICIAN AT
THE TIME I'LL MISS HER I LOVE
HER AND RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THIS. BODY ADJOURNING HER MEMORY
. THANK YOU CENTER POINT. MISTER
COULD. IMPACT NOT ONLY INVESTED
CAL HAS BEEN FILLED BY MANY SO
WE WILL ACTUALLY BRING IN NAME
FOR IT SO WE CAN BE PROFITABLE
MORE LARGE THANK YOU MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO. YOU
WERE RETURNING BACK PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS A
INCREDIBLE BOUNTY OF RICHES. WE
SEE IT TAG TECHNOLOGY WITH OUR
GREAT SELECTION VALLEY WE ARE WE
SEE WITH BIOTECHNOLOGY. SO MUCH
OF IT BASED IN NORTHERN SAN
DIEGO WE SEE WITH HOLLYWOOD. THE
WONDERFUL MOVIES AND MUSIC THAT
CONTINUES TO ROCK THE WORLD AND
WE CERTAINLY SEE WITH GREAT
LEADERS PRESIDENTS GOVERNORS
SPEAKERS. THAT HAVE COME FROM
OUR GREAT STATE THE DRIVE THE
CHANGE TO IMPROVE THE STATE AND
THE NATION. BUT WE'RE ALSO SEE
THAT IN THE AREA OF ATHLETIC
ACHIEVEMENT. THIS PAST YEAR. WE
SAW THE FANTASTIC PLAYER THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS. AND OF COURSE
THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS IN THAT
GREAT SERIES COMPETING TO BE THE
NATIONALLY CHAPS. AND WE ALL
ENJOYED THAT THAT WONDERFUL
ATHLETIC ACCOMPLISHMENT. AND
MEMBERS WE GET TO SEE IT AGAIN
THIS WEEKEND. BECAUSE WE GET TO
SEE THE INCREDIBLE SAN FRANCISCO
FORTY NINERS. I HISTORY A LEGACY
. SECOND TO NONE. JOE MONTANA
ROGER CRAIG JERRY RICE RONNIE
LOTT THE LIST OF GREAT ATHLETES
FROM THAT TEAM. WOULD MAKE THE
ALL STAR TEAM. FOR OUR COUNTRY
THEY ARE SO GOOD NOW THEY ARE
PLAYING ANOTHER WONDERFUL TEAM.
THE INGLEWOOD RAFTS. ADD THAT
THAT THAT TEAM HAS ALSO HAD A
VERY NICE SEASON. THEY WANT THEY
WANT A FEW GAMES THEY'VE THEY'VE
MADE IT THIS FAR- AND IT'S A
IT'S A GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR
ALL THOSE WONDERFUL PLAYERS
WHOEVER THEY ARE ON THAT TEAM.
BUT THE EYES OF THE NATION. R.
I. CALIFORNIA THIS WEEKEND. TO
WATCH THESE TWO MARVELOUS. TEAMS
COMPETE HOPEFULLY SAFELY- AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD. SO WE LIKE TO SAY
TOGETHER GO FORTY NINERS MAY BE
A GREAT COMPETITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE
CITY OF SANTA CLARA. SIX MISTER
PRESIDENT ANY FURTHER SENATOR
ALSO. CLOSE SENATOR WHAT KASKI
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE SENATE
HERE FOR THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA
I WANT TO OPEN MY ARMS TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO- WATCH THE
FOOTBALL GAME THIS WEEKEND SAN
FRANCISCO FORTY NINERS ARE
CELEBRATING THEIR SEVENTY FIFTH
YEAR IN THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL
LEAGUE AND THEY'VE TOGETHER WITH
THE RAMS REALLY HAVE HAD A
MIRACLE SEASON THERE SAID THIS
IS A LOT OF PEOPLE WATER THAT WE
REPRESENT- NEVER GAVE EITHER ONE
OF THESE TEAMS A CHANCE TO GET
INTO THE CHAMPIONSHIP. AND IS AS
WE STRUGGLE THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
WE STRUGGLED WITH ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY ON ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE LOOK TO IS OUR HEROES
ARE IN OUR SPORTS TEAMS AND THIS
WEEKEND IS REALLY A PLATFORM
BEFORE THE SUPERBOWL WHICH IS
ALSO GOING TO BE IN INGLEWOOD
THIS YEAR. END UP ALL. THAT CITY
OF THIS FRANCISCO FORTY NINE-
REALLY HAVE CAPTIVATED PEOPLE
IMAGINATION NOT ONLY IN THE BAY
AREA AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND HOW
THEY AGAINST ALL ODDS WHETHER
IT'S SNOWING OR RAINING STORMS
THEY HAVE MANAGED TO SOMEHOW-
WHEN THE GAME AND LIKE MANY OF
US HERE IN THE SENATE WE MAY BE
IN PERFECT BUT WE ALWAYS GIVE
OUR HEART AND GIVE HER BACK SO.
GO FORTY NINERS. THANK YOU.
SENATOR RAZA. ALL I CAN SAY IS
GO RAMS. LED BY STAFFORD AND CUP
ON DONALD AND RAMSEY THEY'RE THE
TEAM THAT IS GOING TO BRING IT
HOME AND ALL I CAN SAY IS THE
WAY WE SAY IT IN SO FIVE STADIUM
WHICH BY THE WAY WAS BUILT ALL
UNION. WHOSE HOUSE RAM'S HOUSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE BETTER CLARITY
. SENATOR ARTILLERY. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO KNOWLEDGE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE ENTIRE NATION
AND BE LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA AND
THE TWO BEST TEAMS IN PRO
FOOTBALL AND IF YOU'RE GONNA FLY
WITH THE EAGLES YOU CAN FLY WITH
THE RAMS YOU CAN FLY WITH THE
FORTY NINERS WE'VE GOT A FLY
WITH CALIFORNIA SO I'M SO PROUD
OF BOTH TEAMS AND I THINK THAT
IS THE POLITICALLY CORRECT THING
TO SAY. BUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DOES HAVE A GREAT CITY OF
INGLEWOOD AND- THE STADIUM IS
THERE IT'S A BEAUTIFUL STADIUM
AND I KNOW ALL OF YOU WILL BE
WATCHING. AND YOU'LL BE THEN
JOINED WHAT A BEAUTIFUL PLACE TO
BRING THESE TWO GREAT TEAMS
TOGETHER SO GO CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. SENATOR COM LARGER. THE
WEATHER CARE ACT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TWO WANT TO STAND
AND SAY GO. LA INGLEWOOD RAMS-
YOU KNOW THIS TEAM TRADED THEIR
NUMBER ONE PICK THEY HIRED A
ROCKSTAR COACH. THEY BECAME REAL
CONTENDERS THEY BUILT A
BEAUTIFUL WELCOMING UNION
STADIUM. AND WHILE THEY HAVE
SUFFERED SOME LOSSES BY THE
FORTY NINERS I JUST HAVE TO SAY
DON'T COUNT US OUT WHY I ASK YOU
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THE RAMS
BEAT TOM BRADY TWICE THIS YEAR
LITERALLY THEIR FIRST PLAY OF
THE SEASON AND SO FIVE STADIUM
WAS A TOUCHDOWN PASS STAFFORD TO
COOPER KUPP. LEADS THE LEAGUE IN
EVERYTHING. JAYLEN RAMSEY IS
HANDS DOWN THE BEST DEFENSIVE
BACKS IN THE LEAGUE AND AARON
DONALD WILL HAVE HIS WAY WITH
THE FORTY NINERS I'M SORRY TO
SAY. NOW YOU ALL KNOW THAT I'M A
CHICAGO GIRL BUT I'M CALLING IT
RIGHT HERE. THIS WEEKEND IT IS
RAMPS BY FOUR POINTS LET'S GO
RAMS. THANK YOU SENATOR. NEXT UP
THE CINNAMON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I'M A HUGE FOOTBALL
FAN I'M EXCITED TO BE GOING TO
THIS GAME AND I THINK THESE TWO
TEAMS TO REPRESENT THE BEST OF
CALIFORNIA- THEY'RE YOUNG IN
INNOVATIVE THEY ARE RISK TAKERS
ARE YOU GET JIMMY G. WHO IS A I
THINK THE GREATEST QUARTERBACK
IN THE NFL HE'S HOLLYWOOD
LOOKING GUY BUT HE HAS STRUGGLED
A LOT OF ADVERSITY. LET THIS
NINERS TEAM GOT MATT STAFFORD ON
THE OTHER SIDE- YOU KNOW I'M
EXCITED ABOUT WHOEVER WINS THIS
IS ME GREAT GAME FOR CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE DEFINITELY GOING TO
REPRESENT- THE NFC IN THE SUPER
BOWL SO EXCITED ABOUT THAT
EXCITED ABOUT SO FIVE STADIUM
BEING THE SITE OF THE SUPERBOWL
THIS YEAR- AGO INGLEWOOD RAMS GO
FORTY NINERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER. SENATOR RUBIO
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO THANK MY- CALL IT THE
GREAT SENATOR FROM SANTA CLARA-
I THINK- IT IS A FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING. IN THIS
REGARD ALL EYES ARE ON
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME GREAT
TEAMS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
CLARA STATE IT. ODD THAT THE SAN
FRANCISCO FORTY NINERS HAVE
CAPTIVATED THE PEOPLE'S HEARTS
ACROSS THE NATION I WOULD
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES NOT TO
SPECULATE TO STICK TO THE FACTS
ON THIS GREAT SENATE FLOOR AND
GO AROUNDS. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND IT'S
GREAT ROBERT RIVALRY. NINETEEN
NINE MR MAJORITY LEADER BLEW THE
DUST IS CLEAR. YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE GREAT WORK THIS WEEK AT
TWO ALL THE NUMBERS AND OF
COURSE AT THE DESK. P. AND AT
WHICH TIME ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE PLACE WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE AT MONDAY TWO PM AND
HERE'S TO A GREAT WE CAN OF
GOLDEN STATE FOOTBALL. THANK YOU
THE SENATE WILL BE RECESSED
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
IN IT THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
IN PLACE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM- RAMPS.